hello eric rrrr orson
hello donuts
yeah magnus is gonna be tricky with the
knights
oh he's down the exchange
a minute
wait but now white's up
six pawns
one two three four five
i can count to six
now only five pawns
ooh the knight is trapped so knight
versus five pawns
oh this is so funny
oh he's gonna do the rosen trap get
ready for us yes rosentrap
i'm so proud of him
oh i saw that coming too
oh that was so beautiful
he just rose and trapped carlson
is that the first time ever
oh i'm so glad i caught that
and danya knew what to go for like he he
sprinted his knight to f7
oh he could have taken the queen
he could have taken the queen
oh that's so funny but he played knight
of seven
going for the
idea and then
queen c7 magnus wants to sack the queen
for the knight to simplify
king g8 and then takes
and
this happens so often it's crazy
because you assume the king's gonna go
back so you pre-move some pawn move
but then
king h8
and b6 stalemate
so this is a video from maybe a week or
two ago
what a freaking stupid
oh sorry if it's not family friendly but
so far it's okay
just wait for it wait for it
thank you eric rosen you're welcome
thank you eric rosen you're welcome this
is this is eric rosen wherever he is in
the world right now i'm right here
i'm gonna like give him a thousand i'm
gonna
this is
this would not have happened without
eric rosen you're welcome
just clip this and send it to eric uh
well i found it on my own
but a thousand what
he didn't specify the noun